– Ja, okay.
Vielen Dank.
Auf Wiederhören!
– Und?
– Also, es gibt gute Nachrichten und
es gibt schlechte Nachrichten.
Die gute:
Wenn eine ärztliche Verordnung vorliegt,
dann bezahlt die Versicherung die Reha.
– Das ist doch fantastisch.
– Ja. Und die schlechte Nachricht ist,
dass Sie in dieser Zeit möglicherweise
kein Gehalt bekommen.
– Was?
Aber Papa ist doch krankgeschrieben!
Das Problem ist, dass Sie einen
befristeten Arbeitsvertrag haben,
der diese Woche ausläuft.
Wenn Sie nicht arbeiten,
dann wird Ihr Arbeitgeber den Vertrag
bestimmt nicht verlängern.
Deshalb muss er Sie
auch nicht weiter bezahlen.
– Aber Papa hat immer gut gearbeitet.
Es gibt keinen Grund …
– Selma …
– Nein, das ist ungerecht!
– Wir können da leider nichts machen.
– Was ist mit der Unfallversicherung?
Mein Vater hatte den Herzinfarkt
doch während der Arbeit.
– Selma, es war aber kein Arbeitsunfall.
– Und wie sollen wir
unsere Miete bezahlen?
– Das kriegen wir hin.
Wir werden eine Lösung finden.